hey guys Pete here this will be a
Westworld season 3 episode 2 trailer
breakdown actually this trailer is one
of those in the weeks ahead promos that
HBO's been doing after the premieres of
their shows lately so some of the scenes
are likely from later in the season but
either way I will break all of these
down scene by scene and we'll talk about
what might be happening in episode 2 the
title is the winter line which was a
series of German and Italian military
fortifications in Italy we saw may even
more world in the post-credits scene in
episode 1 and this title would suggest
we'll be spending some more time there
with her before we get into it this is
your spoiler warning this video will
contain spoilers for everything that's
happened in West world to this point
including trailers that are out there
that came out before the season if
you're not caught up this video won't be
for you and you have officially been
warned the trailer opens with some night
shots whoever the hail is in host
Charlotte's body is looking at the del o
stead quarters building this is the city
of arts and science building in Valencia
Spain but in the background the West
world creators have pasted it in the San
Francisco skyline so in the 2058 world
where the story takes place she's at the
Del OHS building and that is in San
Francisco California it's a transition
shot of a drop of blood falling into
water it's coming off of someone's hand
it's not clear who the hand belongs to
that cuts to a shot of Dolores and hose
tail and what looks like the house that
Arnold built outside the park where
season two came to an end
there's a voiceover conversation
Charlotte says where am I Who am I
Dolores responds let me show you who you
need to pretend to be while they talk we
see Hale looking into a handheld mirror
as Dolores looks on unfortunately there
aren't any clues about which host
consciousness is inside the Hale body at
this point the takeaway here is that
whoever it is that host will have to
adapt to playing this role the
voice-over continues Charlotte says
where am I going and Dolores answers
home we see Hale walking down a hall in
a different location and based on what's
said and what's going on it could be her
returning to her own house or her
apartment and that transitions to a shot
of a child laying and
my first thought was this was Charlie
Arnold's son but the more I look at it
the more I wonder if Hale didn't have a
son of her own we really don't know
anything about her life outside of her
job outside of the park this is
obviously a different actor than the kid
that played Charlie which that guy would
be too old to play this role again at
that point so that's not any kind of
conclusive evidence but I'm leaning
towards it making more sense that
Charlotte has the son of her own rather
than being another Charlie flashback let
me know in the comments who you think it
is because it's a mystery at this point
after that we see the man in black who
appears to be going through some [ __ ]
he's fully clothed submerged in a
bathtub with a gun in his hand he rolls
out onto the floor and it definitely
feels connected to his wife Juliet
remember she overdosed and he found her
in the overflowing tub when she died
later in the trailer we see him walking
around with those same clothes and the
same gun in his hand and it's inside his
own house he fires a bullet into a
mirror and generally looks like he isn't
holding up well after killing his own
daughter Emily inside the park at the
end of season two and other trailers
we've seen them in a different location
with Dolores which it almost looks like
a clinical setting and since there's
none of that here I'm really not gonna
go down that rabbit hole at this time we
see that Bernard has made it back to the
park it's destroyed this location was
actually burnt down in the California
wildfires last year so these shots look
pretty interesting he's just making his
way through the park I mentioned in my
breakdown video of the first episode
that it's not likely that they'll be
opening Westworld back up even though
the other parks are still operational we
hear Hale say why did you bring him back
in Delores answers we all have our role
to play I wish I could say that this
gives us a better idea of who is in
Hales body but it really doesn't we
assume that she's talking about Bernard
since we're looking at Bernard but I
can't think of any consciousness that
would be more or less interested in
Bernard being brought back so there's
that as he's talking we see Kaleb and
Dolores in the overpass where episode
one ended as he's trying to keep her
alive we see police lights in the
distance sort of lighting up the tunnel
inside the park Bernard says Dolores I
don't know what she's planning but I
can't stop her not
we see that he's talking to Stubb's who
replies Maeve you came back from Maeve
so Bernard and Stubbs are going after
Maeve who's in war world there's a shot
of them walking with drone hosts in the
background that cuts to made standing in
the middle of a chaotic scene inside a
war world and she's frozen all the hosts
around her like we saw her be able to do
let's see her walk away from the scene
then we see a shot of a car from a
distance which we've seen in other
trailers and this is probably her with
Hector driving down the road then we see
your wake up and what looks like the
real world there's a shot of her walking
with a print of one of those Rehoboam
circles that they used to show the
locations in the first episode behind
her we hear vincent cassell voice and
the voice-over and we meet his character
for the first time he says I've waited
many years for you and Delores and the
others to arrive too which made replies
and who the [ __ ] are you there's more
than one conversation here based on what
they're wearing and there's a shot of
Dolores with the pearls she smuggled out
at the end of the season one of them
looks red or maybe it's just got blood
on it I'm not exactly sure if it is red
that would be interesting because we
know that the hybrid pearls the ones
that were based off of humans were
actually printed red
he says she has five more of your kind
under her control they have a head start
and I suspect they're taking full
advantage of it she says oh they better
have this is probably the CEREC that
martin Connells mentioned was in control
of her hoe bone before Delores killed
him and replaced him with a host copy
Liam jr. said he couldn't control
Rehoboam which his father Liam senior
bill he said after his father died his
partner locked Liam out of the system in
all signs point to this being the guy
who's in control of it it's all a bit
confusing we can gather the Bernard and
Stubbs get made out of the park but then
it's hard to say how she ends up here
all the trailers have made it seem like
she'll go head to head with Dolores but
it's hard to understand why she would
side with the humans really I think it
makes more sense that all the remaining
hosts will end up working together in
one way or another by the end of things
but it appears that Maeve is buying
whatever CEREC is selling at least at
first she may have ulterior motives
there may be more going on than what we
can tell and we're just gonna have to
wait and see there's a couple more shots
of stubs in Barnard in the park we see
Barnard sitting at a desk and we watch
Tubbs overpower as a security guard it's
kind of interesting in the background we
see that it looks like it's in medieval
world like the hosts are all dressed in
medieval clothing and that seems to
confirm another Park in the original
West world movie medieval world was
another one of the parks so that's a
nice reference to add and the voiceover
we hear Maeve say who did she put inside
you is that you in there Teddy she's
outside in the real world when we see
her saying it and it cuts to a shot of
hail with like blood on her arm to make
it seem like she's saying it to her but
it seems like two different scenes
edited together she could be saying that
to hail or it could be anybody else
there's a shot later with Martin he's
pointing a gun at someone we know he's a
host so she could be talking to that
character either way this idea that
Teddy might be inside doesn't seem to
make any sense they play a little bit
fast and loose with the rules that they
create themselves so I'm not a hundred
percent sure how that's gonna play out
but they've said that hosts that pass
into the sublime are gone like they're
not going to be coming back so that
would be a bad twist in my opinion I
mean they have this overhead shot where
we see Dolores spooning with the hail
host and people had thought because of
that that it could be Teddy I would be
really disappointed honestly that was a
good ending for Teddy's character to put
him into the sublime or you know the
valley belle on so I don't want to see
him come back even though I like the
character there's a couple of action
shots we see May rolling up on a group
of guys it's hard to say what's going on
there's a car that speeds around the
corner
then we get a little bit of Caleb we see
him on a construction site up on one of
the floors that's not finished it looks
like he's about to execute somebody with
a bullet in the back of the head like
execution-style there's a shot of him
which is probably a flashback but it
looks like it's from his military
service he's running through a jungle or
the woods then we have some voiceover
where someone says who are you and Caleb
responds I'm with her he says that to
Liam and we see Dolores come up for
closing shot of the trailer as far as we
know liam is under the impression that
she's been taken care of like taking out
so this might be a surprise beyond that
it's hard to say what's going on here
except for the fact that caleb and
Delores are working together she has the
host Martin working with Liam so it's
not exactly clear here why she needs to
reveal herself but that's where the
trailer ends a lot of exciting looking
stuff I mean we're gonna get to see some
time in war world we got to find out
that there's a medieval world setting
not sure what they call it it'd be fun
to find out what the name of that one is
and what's going on with that like I
said it's a little bit confusing on what
Maeve's motivation is going to be you
know she's had different drives and none
of them seem to line up with helping the
guy who owns the giant AI in the real
world so it's not clear what kind of a
offer he's going to make to her it's not
clear here what's going on with the main
and black other than he's not doing very
well and I don't see anything that gives
me answers to the questions I want to
know like who are those five pearls so
we'll have to wait and see the Hale
stuff looks like it is a flashback to
before we see her in the board room in
episode 1 it's possible that Dolores
might be moving different pearls into
the same host bodies but I feel like
it's probably the time just before we
saw her when Dolores first rebuilt her
there's a theory out there that Dolores
has more copies of herself I could kind
of see that in the boardroom that that
could have been Dolores is purl and then
now she's putting somebody else in there
to take her place but considering how
they like to play with timelines it
seems more likely that this is just
going to be what came before that how
she slipped into Hales life but let me
know in the comments what you think of
the trailer what you think is gonna
happen in this episode I expect that
it's going to be split between Dolores
and Maeve maven Warworld and her leaving
hopefully by the end of this episode and
then Dolores moving forward with Caleb
and finding out what's up with their
plans so let me know what you think
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel I'll be
doing more Westworld videos throughout
this season thanks for watching I will
talk to you soon